ladies and gentlemen it is now my
privilege to present an honorary award
the Jean Hersholt Humanitarian Award
which is given to an individual in the
motion picture industry whose
humanitarian efforts have brought credit
to the industry the board tonight
unanimously voted dishonor to a
gentleman in our industry whom we regard
as one of the outstanding
philanthropists in the country and I use
the word philanthropist in its true and
proper meaning philanthropy means love
for mankind true philanthropy is the
desire and the readiness to serve one's
fellow Maine the unselfish and
unstinting giving of one's time and
one's energy for the benefit benefit and
welfare of others the a philanthropy
does impose attacks a high-techs on him
who engages in it there are the the time
that one gives will never come again
the energy which one expense is gone
forever
and there is even a surtax in that one
has to forsake the leisurely days and
the restful nights that he might
otherwise might enjoy ladies and
gentlemen the recipient of the award
tonight is a gentleman who for years has
been a true philanthropist who has for
many years practices practice the
sacrifices about which I taught the man
who has traveled far and wide and
brought joy and pleasure and smiles to
many millions the Jean Hersholt
Humanitarian Award goes to mr. Bob Hope
I said to myself this afternoon there
must be a way and they just pushed me in
the wings they said you better watch it
here because I don't know how short this
will be and you have to bounce right on
I'll get you later for this ladies and
gentlemen the Academy this this just I
don't know what to say I don't have
writers for this type of work
I've never had need for him you know but
I really really appreciate this and this
will hold the highest spot in my trophy
room thank you very very much